remember the machete wielding man
arrested outside the capito last week
while it turns out he is an illegal
migrant from Venezuela he was first
spotted pacing back and forth on Capitol
Hill with a brick in his pocket but when
police approached him they realized he
was armed with a machete and a butcher
knife he's charged with carrying a
dangerous weapon and possession of a
prohibited weapon he was first arrested
back in 2022 after illegally crossing
the border into Texas but was released
by border agents due to lack of
detention capacity where have we heard
that before he's now in ice custody and
facing removal proceedings meantime
President Biden is blaming the Border
crisis on Congress as Republicans refuse
to approve a spending bill that bundles
foreign and domestic
Aid
give me the money I need to protect
the you have the money you just need to
enforce the laws the bid Administration
planning to reopen four border ports of
Entry tomorrow that were originally
closed to try and curb the record flow
of migrants this includes Eagle Pass
Texas Sedro California lukeville Arizona
and no Galis Arizona CBP sources tell us
they encountered more than 300,000
migrants in December alone bringing the
total for the fiscal year so far to over
785,000 New York Congressman Mark
Molinaro is in Texas right now with the
speaker of the house and dozens of other
Republicans he joins me live before
their visit to Eagle Pass later today
Congressman thanks for being here um on
the four border ports that are going to
be open I heard a mainstream media radio
station let's say that I'm sure you
listen to when you're back in your
District celebrating that news and also
celebrating that somehow lower numbers
of migrants are coming across the border
thanks to Mexico's efforts it seemed
like a Bizarro world of untruths to me
while you're there right now are you
celebrating anything that you're
seeing I I'll tell you this we're only
celebrating the the heroic and
courageous work of border patrol but the
Frank but but the truth is they're not
given the resources the president has
ignored the crisis and as you know and
you all have reported we we've seen
record number of encounters uh this last
month 700 in 80 plus thousand uh 2.4
million in the last year I mean there is
is true utter chaos and the president
continues to ignore uh what is a
national and humanitarian crisis at our
Southern border and and and so 60
colleagues of mine uh uh are joining the
speaker we're at Eagle Pass uh today uh
we're here to ask the important
questions what what what must we do uh
to finally secure the border and how can
we help uh these men and women who are
every day providing for National
Security at the border the president is
uh is ignoring what is a true uh
National Security crisis I I almost
drove off the road when I heard this
report because it's like an alternative
reality that based upon what you're
saying what our reporters at the border
are saying is just not correct and it
also is having impacts in your District
here in the state of New York what are
the people in your District telling you
about how the Border crisis is impacting
them right
now yeah because of the the president's
failure to act and keep in mind he's got
the tools I even through an emergency
action can take uh uh the steps to
secure the border and uh and to and to
really engage in the appropriate vetting
process to ensure for our own safety but
because of those policies every state
every Community is now a border
community and because of the sanctuary
City policies put in place by New York
City and New York State really
prohibiting law enforcement from working
effectively uh with Federal uh law
enforcement to address illegal
immigration you now have the city of New
York mayor Adams you know really talking
out of both sides of his mouth the
sanctuary City policy in the city uh yet
complaining that uh all of a sudden
there are tens upon thousands of uh
individual uh immigrants coming coming
to the city and then what he of course
is doing is busting them to communities
across the state of New York as well uh
in my own District uh individuals bust
to Liberty New York in the Catskill
region of of New York State forcing even
Democrat Executives Mayors and County
Executives in upstate to declare states
of emergency uh to to prohibit this from
from occurring this doesn't I mean
beyond the national uh uh security
crisis that we face this just isn't the
way to treat human souls and it
certainly isn't the way uh to protect uh
uh this country at our Borders or or
within our communities and it really
does underscore your comment there the
fight within the Democratic party
because you have these Democrat blue
City Mayors albeit Eric Adams trying to
play both sides of the aisle I get that
but but they really are fighting the
administration yet again going back to
this alternative reality narrative that
I have the White House Press Secretary
Karen jeanpierre is lashing out like I
said earlier at Republicans over this
listen the busing of migrants the
putting them on flights it is shameful
that that is occurring and instead of if
the governor really truly wants to deal
with this issue he should talk to uh the
senators in his States we've been in
touch with some of those mayors that you
talked about Governors uh in in Northern
in northern part of the country on
dealing with the issue that they're
dealing with on the ground and we have
provided a resources to them and we're
going to continue to have those
conversations but again Congress needs
to act the president took this very
seriously on day one I I mean so much
wrong with that whole sound B
Congressman take it where you
want well no it's absolutely I mean it's
uh it's absurd to think mayor Adams
begged the president to act uh members
of Congress Republicans and Democrats in
New York said declare a state of
emergency the president chose not to act
and beyond that uh keep in mind the the
Republican majority in the house adopted
the strongest border security bill in
Generations our legislation would secure
the Border would help us to vet
individuals at the border by
streamlining uh the Asylum seeking
adjudication we've given him the tools
and resources they choose not to act and
Bea of it are putting not only
individualized at risk but threatening
the safety of of this country as well it
is just absolutely absurd uh and the
president can act get to the table
negotiate uh and bring forward uh the
house bill to secure a border I mean
look economy is going to be one number
one issue going into 2024's election
we're obviously in 2024 year but boy
this point border is definitely a strong
1A at this point and that is not good
for our country important for
Republicans to drive this point home
that if you want change you may need to
change your leaders Mark Mullen hour
thanks for your time this morning best
of luck today I'm Steve duy I'm Brian
kilme and I'm Angley aart and click here
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page to catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis